[音楽]
100の言葉よりもハグこれは言葉よりも
ハグが大事っていう意味ではないんです
例えば自分が大事な人がすごく心配で
大丈夫って100回心配するんだったら1
回ハグしようっていう意味なんですね
皆さんはじめまして私は
娘を産んだことをきっかけにベビー
マッサージという赤ちゃん専門のタッチ
ケアを伝えてきましたこの100の言葉
よりもハグというのは私が20年前に
母親支援団体を立ち上げた時から自分の中
でとても大事にしている言葉です
今日はコミュニケーションのお話をしにき
ましたなので皆さんにもせっかくなので
参加していただきたいというか協力をお
願いしたいと思ってますとても単純なこと
なのでたった3つのことを協力して
いただきたいと思います一つ目
うなずくことです
同じく一番簡単ですね頷くことすぐやって
くれるわけありがとうございますそして
リアクション取ること
で最後の3つ目が
遠慮しないということです
遠慮しないというのは自分のタイミングで
自分が思ったような表現をしていただき
たいなと思いますなるべく静かにと言われ
たと思いますがこの笑うだったり拍手だっ
たりあとは手を挙げるのかそういう風に
自分で表現をしてもらえるといいなと思い
ます
私は
職業柄たくさんの赤ちゃんと
接してきましたベビーマッサージをしてき
ましたそれですごく不思議に思ったのが2
つあって一つはなんでこの子たち歯がない
のに可愛いんだろう」って私たち
歯がないと可愛くないですよねある意味
可愛いかもだけどもう一つがなぜ私たちと
共通言語がないのにこんだけ
コミュニケーション取れるかってことが
とっても不思議だったんですね
今日は8000人の赤ちゃんたちが私に
教えてくれたことを皆さんにシェアしたい
と思います
最初にコミュニケーションと言いましたが
コミュニケーションすごく難しいんですよ
ね
自分が相手からもらった言葉を
誤解してしまったり
反対自分の言動で
誤解をされてしまうことがあってそれは
メール
文字が一番多いと思いますどのテンション
でこの人たちは私にメールくれてるのかな
ビックリマークついてるから怒ってるのか
なとかあとは
面倒くさいと思われてないか
失礼と思われてないかすごく私は悩んで
しまうんですねでまあ多分もう一歩自分が
コミュニケーションを進められればいいん
でしょうけどちょっと私のこと嫌っちゃっ
たかな私失礼なことしたかなと特に私は
悪い物語を作るのが本当に得意だったので
すごく
私が誤解することが多かったです
怖がることが多かったんですね
だけどこれってコミュニケーションベビー
の教えてもらったコミュニケーションで
少しずつ
克服してきました
はいでは皆さんとのコミュニケーションの
時間になりますご協力お願いします
押さないでください私のことを絶対に
押さないでくださいと言われましたら皆
さんは押しますか押しませんかせーの押し
ませんですそうですはいここら辺でちらっ
と見えるようになってきました終わる頃に
は皆さんも一緒に
参加してくれると嬉しいですそうなんです
だって幼いでって言ってるしキリッとして
ますよねだから押しちゃダメですでは
絶対に
押さないでよって言われたら皆さんは押し
ますか押しませんか今度は皆さん一緒にせ
の推しますですその通りです押すんですよ
ねこれってちょっとせっかく参加してくれ
たらもう1個行こうじゃあこれは本当絶対
んですよ
いいですね絶対に絶対に私のことを
可愛いって
言わないでくださいねって言ったら皆さん
は私のことを
可愛いって言いますか言いませんか
せーの
乾いていい
まあそうなんですこうやって
ベビートークってそうなんですけどベリー
トークって私たちで言語とか
非言語両方が必要とことがここでちょっと
体感していただけたと思いますだから
メールだけだとわからないし声だけでも
わからない
誤解してしまうってことがここでわかって
いただけたかなと思いますでは本題です
まだ本題じゃなかったんですけど本題です
ベビー特区って何でしょう
ベビートークというのは
翻訳じゃない直訳すれば赤ちゃん言葉なん
ですねですが私はベビートークを
コミュニケーション赤ちゃんが取る
コミュニケーション全般として捉えてい
ますで彼らはとっても単純でとても
シンプルな方法で私たちとコンタクト取っ
てくれますそれが一つが
ジェスチャーちょっと大げさな
ジェスチャーそしてタッチですねそして
最後にベビートーク話すことです
声出してないんですけどまあこれが例えば
こうやって興味を持ってもらうのも
赤ちゃんとのコミュニケーションには実は
すごく大切なんですねちょっとさっき
みんなが参加してくれたから調子乗っ
ちゃいましたがこうやって私に興味を持っ
てもらうというのは赤ちゃんだけじゃない
んです赤ちゃんもちろん興味を持って
もらうと例えば頷いたりとかリアクション
取るとすごいよく喋ってくれますこれは
大人も一緒なんですね
なんかこうやって説明とかいろいろ
リアクションとかまあこうやって話をし
なきゃいけない時に
じっとされると皆さんあまり話しにくく
ないですか本来話したいことも話せなかっ
たりするんですけどちょっと笑ってくれ
たりとか
頷いてくれたりするとすごくこっちの演者
って言わないか
遠く登壇者もすごく乗ってくるんですね
こうやってベビートークっていうのはこの
ジェスチャーだったりとかあとはタッチは
今イワナ使わなかったタッチとかあとは
この表現自分たちが伝えきるっていう表現
これがすごく大事ってことが皆さんに
ちょっとお分かりいただけたんじゃないか
なと思います実際に
あのお母さんたちからいろいろ
相談って来るんですね
でベビートークの中ではその
赤ちゃんってとてもシンプルなんですよ
泣きたかったら泣くし起こりたかったら
怒るしですが大人ってちょっと違いますよ
ね
私のところに
子育て中の女性がたくさん
相談に来ます
その時にとても
相談内容としてはすごく深刻です
子供が寝ないんです寝不足です
もっさん私もおっさんて呼ばれてんです
けどもっさん私子育てに自信がないです
もっさん
子供預ける場所がないんです
モンさん私死にたいです
でもね笑ってるのママたち笑ってるのよ
その相談
で何で笑ってるのって聞くと私笑ってまし
たかって泣き出すんだよね
自分が笑ってるって知らないの気づいて
ないの
でもそれって私たちが
成長する中で上手に成長をしてきたんです
よね感情を上手にコントロールできるよう
に生きてきた生きた術なんですよね
怒ってるけど笑っていられるし
悲しいけど涙をこらえることもできます
だけど
そう
ね助けを求める時だけはちゃんと表現し
なきゃダメよね
私たちは全力でコミュニケーションし
なきゃいけない時があるんです
それは
喜びを共有するとき
悲しみを共有するとき
そして
謝罪の時最初に言った
助けを
求めるとき
で
こうやってコミュニケーションするので
すごく大事なのが
相手との衝突を避けることはすごく大事で
じゃあ
毎日すごく仲の良いご夫婦なんだけど毎日
毎日ね
喧嘩をするんですってで喧嘩をするんだ
けど同じことで健康するの4年間それが
靴下事件ってやつなんだけど
旦那さんに
靴下を毎日洗濯機入れてくれない
だからねこれ洗濯機だよねとかなんでこれ
靴下ここに置いとくのって言うと
旦那さんの方もやっぱり言われるとカチン
とくるわけで今やろうと思ったのにとか
うるさいなとか後でやるよっていうことで
喧嘩になりますよね普通にですが女性がね
ママが相談来た時に1回ベビートークを
ちょっと勉強してってそれをちょっとすぐ
に家で試したそうです
その時にねこの靴下ここに置くのはいい
ちゃんですかダメちゃんですか」って言っ
た時に
旦那さんが
ダメちゃんですと4年間中で初めて洗濯機
の中に
靴下を入れたという
素晴らしいことがあったんですね
でこうやって感情は起こってますだけど
言語言語はちょっとふざけちゃってますよ
ねで旦那さんが後に聞いた時になんかね
いつもだとそうに当たらなくてのかな
当たり前のこと言われても自分が悪くても
ごめんなさいって素直に言えないけど
やっぱちょっと今回は逃げ道があったよう
な気がするっていう風に言っていました
私たちはこうやって
頷くとか
リアクション取るとかあとはその言語と
非言語うまく使ってコミュニケーションが
できるんだなっていう風に思ってますこれ
が赤ちゃんから教わったことなんですけど
実はもう皆さん結構な笑ってくれたり
頷いてくれたりするのでもう皆さんベビー
トークの世界に入り始めています
先ほど話したお母さんの感情の部分で言う
と私たちとやっぱり全力でこうやって
コミュニケーションもうまくじゃなくて
いいんですちゃんと感情に乗せてもいいし
感情を乗せなくてもいいけどきちんと伝え
なきゃいけないさっき言った
助けを求める時ですよね
で
もし私が
ニコニコして自分もそうですけど自分の
悩みは自分だけのものって思うこともある
と思うんだけどもし自分の大事な人とか
仲間が
ニコニコしてるんですいつもニコニコして
ますだけど突然次の日に
職場に来なかったらどうしますか
学校に来なかったらどうしますか
もっと言うと自分の命を
粗末にしたらどうしますか
言ってくれたらいいのにって思いますよね
夜中でも電話してよってきっと言うと思う
んです皆さん
一緒です
皆さんを大事に思う人はきっと同じこと
言うと思うんです言ってくれたらいいの
にって
だから私たちは最初に言ったようにうまく
感情をコントロールできるから相手が
悲しいとかって家族でもわかんなくなる時
ありますだから後でこうだったんだって
言われるのってすごく悲しい力なりたいっ
てみんな思ってるもんだから
自分の大事な人を大事にするとか愛す
るってきっと自分のことを大事にすること
なのかなって思います
とはいえですね数年前まで私は自分のこと
大事にするってこんだけ20年間ずっと
ママに言い続けたのにできてなかった
自分は無価値だと思ってたし自分が動けば
いろんな人が
迷惑かかると思ってた
だけど
それを変えてくれる出来事があってそれが
数年前に父が
危篤になったんです
そうするとですねいつもの悪い癖が出て
私がなんかお父さんを心配ばかりさせた
からだなきっといろんな心配かけて間違っ
たんだなってきっと思うんです
ただこの時だけは説明つかない自分の頭の
中に
慈しむという言葉だけが出たんです
たださ
40何年間そんなことしてなかったのよ
やり方がわかんなかっただけどじゃあやり
方わかんなかったらいつもやらないこと
やろうと思ってお風呂に入りました
いつもやってますよお風呂は入ってますだ
けどお風呂入ってるんだけど
丁寧に自分の体を洗ってることってなかっ
たんですよねだから足の小指から洗ってみ
ました1本ずつ大地に大事にその時に涙が
ねポロポロ出てきちゃって
お父さんもお母さんもこうやって私の指を
一本一本大事に洗ってくれたんだろうなっ
て
そこまで大事に思ってる娘が自分のこと無
価値だなんて思ってたらどう思ったん
だろう
私のことをまっすぐ愛情を注いでくれる娘
はどうやって見てたんだろう
私のことを支えてくれる夫はどんな気持ち
で私を見ていたんだろうと思ったら
人を大事にするってきっと自分のことを
大事にすることが大前提なんだろうなって
思いました
私たちがはるか昔にやっていたベビー
トーク
これをするだけでそんなはずじゃなかった
とかそういうつもりじゃなかったっていう
誤解が少なくなるかもしれない
あともう一つ分かってくれるはずっていう
そんな小さな誤解も
なくなるんじゃないかなと思っています
そんな父も5年前に亡くなりまして
今も会いたいし今も悲しいんですね5年な
んだけどだけど私たち家族は
悔いはなかった
だって私
父に愛してるってずっと伝えた
もんお父さん大好きって毎日伝えた
なくなるまで
自分のことを粗末にしませんって誓った
夫は
お父さんの息子になれてよかったって伝え
たから
当時中学生の娘は言葉なくただただ父に
抱かれていた愛を体中で表現してい
た母は
死が思う死の恐怖も痛みも
私たち家族から離れる
寂しさも
一手に引き受けてくれた
父と一緒にそれが父の
命な亡くなるその瞬間まで
母はずっと背負ってくれただから私たちは
悲しいし今でも会いたいけど
悔いがなかったんだと思います
私たちって
私たちじゃないかまず私はもしかしたら
明日なんか来ない日は絶対来るんです私に
絶対来るんです明日が来ないってもしかし
たら私の大事な人にも明日が来ない日は
絶対来るんです
でもその時に
悲しいだけで
後悔が少なくなるといいなと思います
最後に
ベビーが教えてくれたことを皆さんにお
伝えします
ちゃんと笑ってちゃんと怒って
ちゃんと泣いて
ちゃんと助けを呼びましょう
もし言葉がなかったら手があります皆さん
には手があります手がなかったら足でも
いい体でもいい
この手はもし自分の大事な人が
辛くて
唇をかみしめるようなことがあったら
頬に手を打ってあげればいいし
辛くて
背中を丸める人がいたら
背中をさすってあげればいい
抱きしめてあげればいい
そんなことができたらトゲトゲした関係も
きっと
柔らかくなるんじゃないかなって思ってい
ます
すごいよねってこれグーにしたら
人を攻撃することができるのに開いて
触ってあげれば
口美しく世界一優しい言語になる
こんなことが世界に広まったらきっと世界
はもっと優しくて
丸くなるんじゃないかなって
信じています
最後まで私とアイコンタクトを取ってくれ
てコミュニケーションを取ってくれて
本当にありがとうございます
[拍手]